Identify products based on their barcode with
Seeing AI.
So Seeing AI plays audio cues to give you
an indication of when it first recognizes
the possible presence of a barcode.
The faster the beeps, the closer you are,
and then eventually you’ll hear a description
of what the product is.
So for example, here I have a jar.
I’m going to hold the phone over the jar,
parallel with it.
Maybe one foot away.
The distance to the object depends on how
big it is.
The larger, the further away you would want
to be.
So, the phone is over the jar and I am not
hearing anything.
So let’s slowly rotated it until we hear
the beeps.
> (beeping)
There are other beeps, so let’s keep going.
> Processing
> Barney Butter Barney and Company, Almond
Butter Crunchy, button.
Cool!
Peanut butter.
I like that.
Let’s try something else.
So I have another product here.
This time it is a box. and with a box, there
are six possible sides which I would have to
scan.
In actual fact, it could be anywhere on those
six sides.
So I am going to hold the phone quite a bit
further away this time so the camera can see
the entirety of one side at a time.
So , we are not seeing anything on that side.
And try another one.
> (Light beeping sound)
Woo!
> (Faster beeping sound)
That’s lucky!
> Annie’s Homegrown Microwavable Gluten
Free Mac & cheese – 5 CT.
Wow!
Great!
So mac and cheese, and I was lucky i got it
on the second side this time.
So to recap, we use bar codes to identify
what a product is.
Hold the phone over the object you want to
recognize, maybe about a foot away.
But you should try different distances based
on the size.
Make sure the phone is parallel, and start
rotating the object until you hear the beeps.
Make slight adjustments until the beeping
gets faster and you hear the description read
out.
Sometimes, you’ll hear that more information
is available, like the instructions on the
package.
Now, I better get back to putting away my
groceries.
Microsoft logo appears